alright so let's talk more about nature
or at least fake nature but beautifully
created fake nature the DreamWorks
Animation foliage system yeah all right
laughs uh where was that was developed I
got it Bob developed over 17 years
starting with the oscar-winning Shrek
and most recently seen in how to train
your dragon 2 as animated films create
more fantastic worlds they need the
summary the need to art direct digital
trees and bushes has grown oh wow that's
that joke again with the stylization of
DreamWorks animated movies it's critical
that model is focused on unique design
and rich detail and not just growing
plain old trees built into the foliage
system is a modeling tool called bonsai
this artist driven tool has married art
direction and foliage creation enabling
artists to model trees in a fraction of
the time along with generating natural
and believable environments on a grand
scale for their design and
implementation of the DreamWorks
Animation foliage system the Academy
presents the technical achievement award
to Scott Peterson Jeff buds Berg and
Jonathan Gibbs
you
first just thank you to our wives Chris
Tiffany Mandy this journey began on
shrek when Ken bielenberg asked Jonathan
and I to create forests which had never
been done before we quickly found out
that creating trees that were pretty was
difficult so it wasn't until two
thousand seven when Jeff buds Berg came
to foliage that tree creating trees
actually became pretty trees became an
easy thing to do we dedicate this award
to PDI
PDI who made this possible by creating
an institution where art and science
combined to create beautiful images
thanks to Kolya erman Landon gray josh
west jeff floods berg jeff his David
Hart Bruce tell tia and to the Academy
to our parents love you mom and dad
again many thanks to my wife Tiffany who
has supported me over the years and
without her this wouldn't be possible
thanks to the many artists at DreamWorks
and PDI my heart goes out to them and I
love you dearly thank you for everything
I just like that a thank you to my mom
and dad to my kids Lucy and Jackson to
my wife mandy who put up with me coming
late from home late from work way too
many times and from everyone who's ever
worked at PDI for making a place where
for giving me a job that was just way
too fun to have thanks